[Music]
it's been a while oh yeah we haven't
talked about angelic yields yet
angelic yields
that's so funny cover the angelic eating
we do even talk about the four losers
who went into space
oh yeah [ __ ] spacex you know
i mean they're not losers but
i like how they the highlight of that is
it's for regular people who went into
space and orbited for three days and
came down you know astronauts are doing
what we were doing a few weeks ago no
they just make it seem like anybody can
do it yeah yeah not anyone can be an
astronaut yeah we can
yeah we can
so wait i what what was this this was
the first commercial flight yeah done by
spacex
and so four like rich people went up in
space
they were just right
uh it was a sweepstakes so one
person was selected as a former
cancer patient
uh one person that's not funny
it wasn't a joke
that's not
why you guys laughing i'm no one's
laughing you guys just laughed it's not
funny
i'm laughing at luke it wasn't a joke
so you're laughing again i don't
anyways yeah so sorry go ahead they were
all civilians and uh all chosen to go on
this flight for different reasons
but none of them paid to go
and one of them had cancer
one of them was a former cancer patient
okay got it one of them won luke that's
kind of [ __ ] up dude
it's not a joke
all right
okay i wonder what the [ __ ] this is like
doing what they did with
elon was it elon that went up no it was
uh branson was branson and jeff bezos
now elon is the third
this is the billionaire space race
so but these are like random people that
went up in space and came back down
mm-hmm did they actually go into orbit
yeah for three days really for three
days yeah
holy [ __ ]
three days man that's crazy i just want
to know what that's kind of [ __ ] on
the other two yeah that's what he yeah
that's why i say billionaire space race
he's like
but elon wasn't actually on the thing no
okay hell no still that's a sick flex
yeah it's like what you guys touched the
[ __ ]
oh you touched the outer rim of this
guess what guess what [ __ ] i sent four
poor people up there yeah
you know
branson and bezos are pissed like why
didn't we think about doing that yeah
yeah that's what the space race is going
to be they don't want to go to mars and
all that [ __ ] they just want to send
people up there to die in jesus christ
maybe i should put this in my set
this is them before dorks oh they chose
nerds man look at him so excited to die
hi
oh my god dude so would you ever ever
get on this [ __ ] ship if that was the
space suit no that ship we know this
one's safe they look up bro they look
like backup dancers for a super bowl
performance
go back to that hi
oh i'd be yeah can't wait
dude
sorry but what's wrong dude this [ __ ] is
so dangerous still isn't it what like
they have to tell them like listen guys
we chose you
you're the lucky you're the lucky
winners
you're going into orbs yo they even got
a big bald guy hoping they turn them
into a [ __ ] human rock it looks like
jeff bezos that was them [ __ ] on
bezos yeah and we got a ball guy to go
up too higher than you
and he's way less rich than you two dude
imagine they created the actual
fantastic four with this they touched
down and that [ __ ] dude on the right
like in the back he comes down and his
limbs just keep getting longer and
longer he's like whoa whoa
bald guy pops his helmet off he's just
stoned just
what the [ __ ] is wrong with my face how
scared would you be to your point about
how dangerous this is how much more
scared would you be when you went to
suit up and half of your suit was
[ __ ]
rain boots
a utah mother's like gardening boots
not even attached yeah just like not
even just sewing into the suit just toss
those boots on over top that's some good
marsh boots right there
[Laughter]
some good fly fishing boots right there
if you make it you should definitely
keep those yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying do they think do you think they
like sat them down they're like all
right you're doing this but there's like
a 50 chance yeah that you're never
coming back yeah definitely i think you
think 50 i think that's a nice
i think it's like
80 chance
yeah i don't know odds of coming back
have to be low as hell
they were up there for three days that
can't be true is that true
that's i feel like we would have seen
him they were up there for three days
also doing what
just orbiting pissing and [ __ ]
orbiting the planet like
dude six hours into that it'd be like
all right
yeah
we should probably go back there's
nothing else to do up here yeah what do
you do if you have like a panic attack
or something up there you just yeah
exactly
it's like does anyone did anyone bring
any games they're like we got backgammon
they pull it out and all the pieces like
oh
damn it damn it didn't think that
through
they're just away from cars
[ __ ] god
they just run through
you know their ipad battery watching
like tv yeah [ __ ]
no one brought a lightning cable
yeah i wonder what the inside of this
thing is like was it just that that's
not the same was there like a a room
that they could hang out in or something
oh can you imagine getting up there and
one of them talks way too much like you
just don't vibe at all yeah like damn
this is crazy oh my god this completely
reminds me of a time
you're like oh
i don't talk this much
okay
that's what they went up in
what we're gonna die in
straight up bro
they are way too eager for us that's
them i'm landing dead yeah in a sack
no row it that's just it looks like a
potato sack it's like all four of them
just jammed in that thing it looks like
a banana seed bro just that's pretty you
know be funny legendary if that's the
part they died in
oh yeah they made it
the rope [ __ ] breaks no no no just
drop like 200 meters into the ocean
[Laughter]
oh no oh no oh no
no it's the [ __ ] it's coming down
and like the side door opens and all
pouring off
yeah
one of the cables in the parachute
disconnects or does like that like
jerking motion and just empties them
like cereal just [ __ ]
so [ __ ] up
that's why i ran the bonus
yeah
i'll hit the water
[Music]
just doing like that starfish
so close so close [ __ ]
the latch just goes
pour out like dog food bro just
[ __ ] three days in literal orbit and
they die in the last point zero five
percent of the trip and then [ __ ]
dude and like all that lack of gravity
up there just [ __ ] with their bones and
muscles so they can't swim like they
just hit the water and just oh jesus
i know it's grim that's dark that's my
stuff i'm glad they made it back i mean
that has to feel incredible now
yeah do you think like you you come back
with a weird depression
maybe no i'm serious like that's a whole
another side to this that we haven't
considered
like returning back to earth it's just
not the same dude
i've seen what it's like out there or
it's where i belong does it like [ __ ]
with your perception of everything yeah
maybe
it may be just yeah maybe just come down
and you're just kind of like just a
little bit
weird now yeah like a peyote trip or
something like that
or ayahuasca yeah you're like you
haven't fully
integrated the learnings dog that's
that's the 2025 ayahuasca trip yeah just
paying paying hacks to take you to space
that's gonna be the year 2100 people
with shitty space bikes and like pods
attached to them like i could take you
up shamans yeah space shamans yeah it's
a [ __ ] harley davidson strapped to
like a turbine motor
and then
a [ __ ] space proof uh sleeping bag
yeah i found a space shaman in venice
like he's got a sick bike dude i've
always wanted to do that you should
totally go oh and you just go up and do
mushrooms yeah
that's what you that's what it is it's
just still getting high on the same
drugs yeah in space you don't actually
get to see space yeah you're just in a
foil bag just
[Laughter]
tripping balls man
you